what the lionesses achieved last night
was incredible
[Music]
their performance throughout the
tournament has captivated the nation and
won them a place in the final
manchester city's esme morgan has been
cheering on her teammates who made it
into the england squad so many people
have fallen in love with the team and
the players and the atmosphere around
them that i think it would just be the
perfect ending for a home tournament her
flatmate and teammate is lioness lauren
hemp there said repeat after me i'm
going to win this tournament and she
just said i will i said i want the full
sentence so she said i will win this
tournament
so i think she believes and she's not
the only one there's never been so much
excitement about women's football in
this country more people have watched
this tournament in stadiums and at home
than ever before and the players now
have a huge profile
like alessia russo whose back heel is
going down in football history it's
already legend at the club she played at
as a child
i've seen more back heels here today
than i've seen probably in the last
three years it doesn't matter where they
are they're not all trying to score with
them they're just any part of the pitch
if they're playing the match play
they're all doing back hills it's
brilliant to watch but is the buzz
around this team and this tournament
enough to get more bums on seats at
league games we need to translate that
to for people regularly going out being
able to know where games are being able
to buy tickets affordably um and then go
and support their you know their local
club as well
for the moment it all comes down to this
question is football finally coming home
oh and who will we face on sunday at
wembley france or germany they're
battling it out tonight for a place in
the final and a chance to lift the
trophy becky kochel sky news